bonjour merci d'être avec nous pour ce
premier numéro de dimanche en politique
le nouveau rendez-vous régional et
national de france 3 avec un invité au
coeur de l'actualité christophe sirugue
bonjour bonjour christophe sirugue on
vous avait reçu l'an dernier comme
rapporteur de la célèbre loi travail
vous voilà qu'une grosse semaine
secrétaire d'état à l'industrie et au
coeur de l'actualité avec l'annoncé de
la fermeture du site alstom de belfort
on va bien sûr en parler ce sera une
façon concrète de tenter de répondre à
notre question du jour l'industrie
at-elle encore un avenir en france mais
d'abord et c'est plus personnel vous
entre le gouvernement allait neuf mois
de la fin du quinquennat dans une
ambiance compliquée qu'allez vous faire
dans cette galère mais je crois que je
vais servir mon pays tout simplement et
non plus sur une thématique ou très
sincèrement la question de la durée
c'est pas forcément la problématique
principale problématique principale
c'est d'accompagner les entreprises
d'accompagner les filières d'accompagner
les salariés et vous savez comme moi que
parfois la vie d'une entreprise se joue
en quelques semaines donc j'ai quelques
mois pour essayer de jouer ce rôle de
ces euros le fort parce que je pense
qu'on a besoin d'un renfort du
gouvernement aux côtés des entreprises
avec ironie c'était une dernière chance
d'être ministres ou secrétaires d'état
heureusement qu'on vit pas que pour ça
parce que franchement il y aurait
beaucoup de déçus ils disaient pour
commencer alstom a annoncé la fermeture
de son site de belfort
et
j'arrive à lire mieux sans lui mais
voilà ne sont plus ramassées alstom
prend moins de trains alstom réduit son
activité en quoi le ministre de
l'industrie
doit-il intervenir parce que c'est la
vie d'une entreprise
alstom à des salariés extrêmement
performant alston a les commandes qui
sont certes dans un calendrier qui est
difficile par rapport aux années qui
viennent mais lorsque l'on parle par
exemple du tgv du futur ça veut bien
dire qu'il ya un marché potentiel est
par ailleurs on a des salariés qui ont
la formation nécessaire donc toute la
question qui est posée c'est de savoir
comment on gère cette période difficile
et très sincèrement je trouve que la
réponse très abrupte du pdg d'alstom
n'est pas compatible avec la stratégie
industrielle que le gouvernement entend
soutenir qu'est ce que ces négociations
qui a commencé alstom pape fort en
espérant que le gouvernement va lui
demander d'être de fabriquer des trains
pour revenir sur sa décision c'est ça
qui se passe en ce moment je pense qu'il
ya une déclaration d'alstom qui à mon
sens est une déclaration un peu facile
tout simplement parce que il est lui
aussi responsable de la stratégie
industrielle de son entreprise et en
même temps le gouvernement a dit très
clairement que la filière ferroviaire
c'était une filière d'avenir et donc ce
que je lui ai reproché lorsque j'ai vu
c'est de ne pas avoir fait cette
confrontation entre l'analyse qui est la
sienne et qui tient compte de réalités
la baisse en effet du carnet de
commandes pour les prochaines années et
en même temps la volonté du gouvernement
qu'il l'a montré tgv du futur c'est
quand même bien une volonté du
gouvernement qui est derrière lorsqu il
y a les différentes commandes qui sont
faits sur l'intercités c'est bien la
volonté du gouvernement qui est derrière
donc il y a urgence à trouver cette ce
bien qui ne s'est pas fait en même temps
le cet homme a perdu n'a pas eu des
contrats récents qu'ils espéraient avoir
aidés contrats pour la france oui et en
même temps est-ce qu'il faut du
protectionnisme ce qu'il faut que l'état
français disent bien les trains tous les
trains qui doivent rouler en français
alstom qui les faits mais pouvait pas
faire ça tout simplement parce que
alstom réussi à l'étranger aussi et donc
moi je rappelle très clairement 1 74 %
des exportations dans notre pays sont
des exportations agro industriel si vous
commencez à penser qu'en mettant des
barrières vous allez vous protéger
certes vous allez avoir forcément la
retour de la part des autres pays et
donc une mise en cause de nos
productions de nos exportations donc il
faut que nous ayons plutôt une réflexion
sur le fond qui est de dire comment un
territoire comme belfort qui a un
potentiel qui a un avenir industriel
comment est ce qu'on fait pour
diversifier probablement une partie de
son activité est en effet essayer de
voir comment des commandes peuvent
l'accompagner les autres sites alstom le
creusot par exemple un gros site est ce
que dans la discussion il ya en réalité
des autres sites d'alstom ont pas du
tout on peut pas saucissonner les
différents sites encore une fois une
entreprise comme alstom c'est une
stratégie industrielle globale avec des
marchés différents archer à l'étranger
marché intérieur est nous qui sommes
partie prenante du capital d'aston nous
nous disons très clairement nous ne
voulons pas être les spectateurs ou
simplement être là pour amener du
capital nous voulons être aussi partie
prenante de la discussion c'est ce que
j'ai dit très clairement et les choses
se sont faits de manière rapide parce
que j'ai considéré que cette annonce
dans une période de changement de
ministre me paraissait un peu suspecte
mais dans le communiqué que vous n'avez
plus qu'à publier le message l'économie
communiqué conjoint de michel sapin
était de vous même il n'est pas le mot
d'opposition n'est jamais cité est ce
qu'on doit comprendre que vous ne
pourrez pas vous opposer à la décision
d'alstom au final ou que le gouvernement
a déjà acté éventuellement la fermeture
non le gouvernement n'a pas acté la
fermeture choses sont très claires de ce
point de vue là
deuxième élément nous avons demandé
qu'il y ait un échange sur le projet sur
le son et y compris sur les incidences
que les pdg d'alstom considère comme
inéluctable
nous ne considérons pas que la fermeture
de belfort soit inéluctable je le dis
très clairement ici nous ne le
considérons pas et nous voulons
travailler sur l'ensemble des sites en
effet sur le site de la rochelle sur le
site de belfort sur les autres sites qui
sont implantés en france tout simplement
parce que nous avons besoin de dynamiser
ses ornements franche comté qui
s'inquiète aussi sexy toi et c'est bien
pour ça qu'il faut pas se focaliser sur
des formes même si sûr quel sort est
aujourd'hui au coeur de l'actualité
quelle est la ligne rouge sur ce dossier
pour le gouvernement c'est à dire que au
delà de laquelle la vous dirai non non
non je pense que la ligne rouge c'est
celle qui sacrifie la stratégie qui a
été mis en place par le gouvernement en
terme de dynamique industrielle c'est
celle là concrètement ça veut dire ça
veut dire que le gouvernement dans tous
ses choix depuis maintenant plusieurs
mois a défini neuf secteurs prioritaires
sur lesquels nous avons des enjeux de
stratégie et des enjeux de reconquête
industrielle le ferroviaire fait partie
de ces neuf secteurs là à l'évidence une
entreprise importante dans le domaine du
ferroviaire comme alstom qui
considérerait qu'elle est finalement pas
ténu et participer de cette dynamique
globale et collective je considère que
ce serait là le franchissement de la
ligne rouge que vous évoquez ce que vous
pensez qu alstom de faire le gros dos
attendre d'avoir de nouveaux contrats
attendre que ça aille mieux
c'est ça qui doivent faire en fait et
par est pas fermée ferme et belfort je
considère que alstom doit considérer le
marché intérieur avec la même force
qu'il l'ait fait sur l'exportation ce
qui sous-entend que ça va très bien
quand ils vendent des trains aux pays
bas en italie ce sera au coeur des
échanges avec lui il peut ça peut bouger
encore sur alstom tels que en gros le
pdg d'alstom il peut encore revenir en
arrière est ce que les salariés d'alstom
qui vous écoute là ils ont le droit
d'espérer à belfort la presse nationale
de ce matin évoque le rendez vous de
demain matin que président la république
ça veut bien dire que la mobilisation
est au plus haut niveau et que nous ne
considérons pas que l'annoncent est une
annonce que nous ne pouvons pas discuter
de tous les termes de tous les termes
l'état est le plus gros actionnaire
dalston avec 20% est ce que ça donne
l'état réellement un bras de levier ou
est ce que c'est un peu plus compliqué
que ça ça lui donne une obligation
d'intervention encore une fois vous
pouvez pas être partie prenante d'un
conseil d'administration et ne pas avoir
votre mot à dire 20% en même temps c'est
pas un risque ça a été discuté conseil
d'administration et ben non c'est bien
tout le problème c'est que l'annoncé a
été faite en gros dans une réunion
informelle sans même prendre le soin de
faire remonter cette information vers le
gouvernement une pas même vers celui qui
siège pour notre compte dans le conseil
d'administration
franchement je ne suis pas sûr que ce
soit les bonnes conditions démarrage des
discussions mais on le lui rappeler et
vous allez continuera préfère manger
tous les jours on va étendre à un
barcamp d'alstom le sujet de l'industrie
puisque c'est notre c'est votre
portefeuille principal en rappelant
d'ailleurs que dans la deuxième partie
de cette émission à partir de 12h50
c'est pierre moscovici commissaire
européen socialiste qui sera l'invité de
francis letellier qui connaît bien le
sujet puisqu'il a été mise de l'économie
est ce qu il a surtout été élus du
territoire de belfort on va donc avancer
sur ce sujet de l'industrie et pour
élargir le sujet et se poser la question
est ce que l'industrie peut exister
encore en france on va écouter quelqu'un
que vous connaissez bien à plusieurs
titres c'est andré billardon ancien
maire socialiste du creusot le creusot
une ville frappée de plein fouet
83,84 par la crise industrielle est une
ville qui a cru à l'industrie et une
audi est revenu à son niveau d'emploi de
cette époque là ce qui est assez rare qu
on écoute tout de suite andré billardon
après tout
si l'avenir n'est pas industriel ya
peut-être pas d'avenir pour le creusot
et donc il faut mettre le paquet sur la
question industrielle ça c'est un
raisonnement qui s'est construit depuis
95 5 jusque dans les années 2000 au fil
du temps vous pensez que ça marcherait
aussi bien à ré industrialisation du
creusot quand 84 non en ce sens de la
pensée non on n'avait pas prévu la
situation d'aujourd'hui est aujourd'hui
la situation sinon sinon heureuse du
moins il ya des atouts il ya un socle
industriel il ya des entreprises qui
sont de la mondialisation a un avenir il
ya un avenir par que sucre a pu survenir
dans l'industrie un avenir y compris
dans les pays développés les toujours
cru d'ailleurs le modèle américain l'a
montré
andré billardon c'est quelqu'un qui vous
avez commencé en politique c'est
quelqu'un qui je dois beaucoup en effet
comme je suis plutôt quelqu'un de fidèle
c'est clair que j'ai bien l'intention de
le démontrer d'abord parce que je me
retrouve très clairement dans ce sens
les y aurait bizarrement je pense qu'il
a fait la démonstration sur le
territoire du creusot qu'il y avait un
avenir industriel et je pense la même
chose au niveau national alors pourquoi
ça marche au creusot pourquoi ça n'a pas
marché en lorraine par exemple où les
aciéries
engrangé florange mais parce que il ya à
l'évidence des nécessités de
diversification y compris dans la
filière industrielle il y à des
nécessités de modernisation d'adaptation
et puis il ya des filières sur lesquels
forcément il ya un potentiel plus fort
que d'autres croient dans l'industrie ça
veut pas dire que rien ne bouge croire à
l'industrie ça ne pas dire qu'il n'ya
pas un moment une nécessité quand on
parle de l'industrie du futur puisque
c'est un chantier important qui a été
ouvert par le gouvernement l'industrie
du futur c'est pas simplement
l'industrie des nouvelles technologies
c'est comment est-ce qu'on accompagne
part de l'investissement par la croyance
que l'on peut avoir dans l'intelligence
de nos ingénieurs de nos équipes comment
est ce que l'on fait pour mobiliser les
moyens de telle sorte que nos
entreprises nos industries finalement
franchi cette étape de modernisation et
puis je le dis ici il ya un moment où
j'entends bien que c'est compliqué on a
beaucoup de propension à parler de nos
entreprises qui ont des difficultés
ce serait être tellement bien qu'on
parle aussi de toutes celles qui gal des
marchés qui vont conquérir des marchés à
l'extérieur et à l'intérieur et très
sincèrement dans la pochette que j'ai
trouvé en arrivant dans mon ministère il
ya aussi toutes celles ci toutes celles
qui réussissent la part des choses c'est
quoi l'industrie que les gens
comprennent aujourd'hui c'est à peu près
14 14 3% du pib donc c'est quelque chose
de relativement important et et puis
surtout c'est une chaîne en cascade qui
est extrêmement essentiel également on
parle et d'évoquer la lorraine tout à
l'heure je voulais vous soumettre une
phrase qui avait déclaré alors lakshmi
mittal qui était l'ennemi public numéro
un en france à cette époque là c'est le
patron de mittal qui souhaitait fermer
florange et a déclaré en france le coût
du travail est 20% plus élevés qu'en
espagne est votre droit du travail reste
encore trop rigide ce qui disait en gros
aussi pour eux pour fermer des sites
l'état peut faire quoi par rapport à ça
parce que là c'est un grand patron
internationale qui dit moi en france je
sais plus assez de gagner assez d'argent
donc je m'en vais je crois que les
gouvernements d'abord à montrer sa
volonté d'accompagner les entreprises
cice les plans qui ont été développées
participe de cette volonté là et non pas
comme je l'entends parfois pour faire
des cadeaux aux patrons est tout
simplement parce que nous avons besoin
de renforcer la compétitivité de nos
entreprises je note d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui et nous avons réussi à
revenir en deçà de l'allemagne par
exemple lorsque l'on fait une
comparaison horaires de ce que
représente le travail donc aujourd'hui
nous avons avancé sur ces questions là
nous devons continuer c'est un combat
permanent c'est un combat essentiel et
encore une fois ne faisons pas ce chalet
virage est un peu dangereux qui serait
de considérer qu'ils allaient salariés
d'un côté et les patrons de l'autre une
entreprise c'est des employeurs ce sont
des salariés et c'est cette communauté
la qui fait que ça réussit puisqu'elle
est attractive la france pour des
patrons de l'industrie dans le monde
écoutez quand je regarde les discussion
qui s'engage après le break site je
pense qu'en effet la france est
relativement intéressante elle a un vrai
potentiel est là des vrais chercheurs
est là et vraie filière et ça ce sont
des éléments qu'on ne retrouve pas
forcément dans d'autres territoires je
vous somme une autre phrase d'un
socialiste et fois lionel jospin
qui avait déclaré ça avait fait beaucoup
de bruit à l'époque vous en souvenez
sûrement il ne faut pas tout attendre de
l'état ce n'est pas avec la loi qu'on
régule l'économie sous-entendu il fait
qu'il peut faire quoi le ministre par
rapport à des grandes entreprises en
fait en tout cas pour ce qui me concerne
je ne ferai pas des déclarations comme
d'autres laissant à penser que tout va
se régler disons aux salariés qu'il n'y
a pas de difficultés on va s'en occuper
moi ce que je dis c'est venez autour de
la table les représentants des salariés
les employeurs travaillons ensemble
disons nous les choses soyons honnêtes
dans la présentation des choses quand il
ya une difficulté disons qu'il ya une
difficulté mais quand il a des capacités
sachant aussi trouver les moyens de
prendre toutes les décisions possibles
pour qu'on puisse réussir vous avez eu à
négocier avec kodak loup c'est une
expérience et un groupe d'autres
situations particulières parce que
colette c'était simple comme il pouvait
de toute façon plus vendre d'appareils
photo argentique il ferme et où il n'y
avait pas grand chose à négocier alors
je rappelle quand même qu'il y en a eu à
négocier un contrat de site ce qui a été
parmi les plus importants de france 163
millions d'euros que ce contrat de site
il a fallu se battre pour que ce ne soit
pas simplement de la route des
infrastructures mais que ce soit de
l'aide pour une reconversion
industrielle qui s'opère si on a pu à
chalon sur saône réaménager son nez hors
toute cette zone industrielle nord qui
aujourd'hui réussi c'est aussi parce que
nous avons eu ces cinq compagnons quand
on a accueilli amazon par exemple dont
j'apprends et avec plaisir qu'il y a
encore des contrats à durée indéterminée
supplémentaires par rapport à ce que
nous avions programmé c'est bien
l'ensemble de cette réflexion et c'est
bien pour dire que dans le territoire
ici à peu près la même chose au niveau
national à un moment il n'y a pas de
fatalité il ya les coups durs ça peut
arriver malheureusement il n'y a pas de
fatalité et donc si on travaille
ensemble si on ne se cherche pas des
querelles qu'ils n'ont pas lieu d'être
il faut que nous soyons là pour
accompagner nos entreprises nous parler
de coup dur deux exemples dans votre
département ce phare un long chemin là
il ya un projet de reprise il semble que
les les propriétaires précédents m et
puis alia à digoin mai 2,2 situation du
situation traîne le ministre ancien
député d'un député de ce département il
regarde après ces dossiers là je regarde
tous les dossiers qui dépendent de mon
ministère met à l'évidence sur le
dossier phare de montchanin c'était un
sujet que je suivais de quasiment tous
les jours dans les semaines précédentes
la commissaire au redressement productif
de bourgogne accompagne de manière très
fort c'est toujours les commissaires
hordain bien joué et j'ai bien
l'intention d'ailleurs de les réunir
tout ce sont les entends très bientôt
les entend pas beaucoup je trouve que
c'est un peu dommage qu'au cours des
deux dernières années on est pas montré
combien il était important et combien ce
sont des relais essentiels dans les
différentes régions donc je vais faire
ce qu'il faut pour les remettre j'allais
dire dans le mouvement pour les visites
pour leur dire ma ma confiance et ma
détermination à les faire travailler
tous ensemble donc sur la star il ya en
effet un accompagnement aujourd'hui
important il ya un repreneur une
décision au 16 septembre on va voir
encore une fois là aussi il ya peut-être
à voir quelles sont les perspectives un
petit peu à plus long terme mais c'est
un dossier qu'on suit de très près 30 à
10 voix c'est plus compliqué là c'est le
bois florange qui va s'appliquer pour
essayer de voir comment on peut
accompagner j'ai déjà été interviewé par
les régulateurs en quelques mots ce que
c'est la loi florange c'est l'obligation
qui est faite lorsqu'il y à une
entreprise qui se désengage du
territoire de chercher par elle même
également des potentiels repreneurs de
sitôt d'activité mais lorsque l'on met
sur des mois j'ai désiré lefait pas
l'entreprise parce qu il ya justement
des sanctions d accompagnement qui sont
faits par l'état cela étant sur d'ivoire
j'ai déjà été contacté par les élus par
la députée est il que yo par le maire de
digoin là encore à disposition pour
travailler avec l'ensemble de celles et
ceux qui ont comme moi l'envi de relever
les manches on a parlé d'industrie on va
parler un peu de politique
et pour commencer on va faire pour
prendre un peu de légèreté un petit saut
dans le temps pour rire ce chapitre
regardez cet extrait des archives nous
sommes candidats avec un arrêt brière
dans le sillage
la campagne présidentielle de lionel
jospin nous sommes candidats parce que
nous voulons travailler pour une france
plus juste et pour que notre
circonscription s'inscrivent dans une
france plus juste
il est clair que nous voulons
représenter l'ensemble des sept
circonscriptions avec l'aspect rural que
représente le suppléant et puis la
connaissance notamment de la cité urbain
avec chalon et sa couronne que je peux
incarner dans cette candidature
oui parfaitement je me souviens très
bien parce que c'était la première
élection législative à laquelle j'ai
participé contre dominique perben c'est
une partielle lorsqu'ils avaient été
évacués du gouvernement balladur donc
tout ça je me souviens parfaitement
d'une très belle campagne d'ailleurs
qu'on avait mené avec bernard dit brière
le jeune militant socialiste s'imaginer
ministre non je pense pas qu'on ait dans
ce combat là et dans cette perspective
là on est engagé voilà on est engagé
pour des idées moi j'ai toujours
considéré que mon engagement il était
d'abord sur les valeurs auxquelles je
crois c'est ça qui me paraît le plus
important que vous venez sur le terrain
des valeurs est en fait ces deux là où
je voulais venir après cette archive le
pc était dans l'opposition disent en
2002 2012 en gagnant toutes les
élections locales est-ce que c'est
quasiment la règle en france et en même
temps on a envie de vous dire qu'est ce
que vous avez fait au ps pendant tout ce
temps là pour être si peu d'accord sur
les grands sujets maintenant que vous
êtes au pouvoir aux souhaits tenter de
vous répondre que on a la même réponse
aujourd'hui quand les aventures
individuelles l'emportent sur les enjeux
collectifs on arrive à des situations
catastrophiques on le regarde le débat
aujourd'hui de la présidentielle quand
je regarde que certains finalement sont
déjà dans la presse débat présidentiel
n'est pas qu'on s'étonne que les
électeurs moi je vous m'avez idée vous
sur un certain nombre de points par
exemple protectionnisme ou pas
intervention de l'état ou pas on l'a vu
même au moment de la loi travail on a
l'impression qu'ils avaient quand même
des courants de pensée sur lequel rien
n'a été tranché l'intérêt de votre parti
est ce que c'est la faute de françois
hollande qui a comme était premier
secrétaire pendant très longtemps de
cette période il ya toujours eu au parti
socialiste des composantes diverses avec
un socle bien évidemment qui nous
rassemble on va quand même pas découvrir
aujourd'hui
que notre histoire collective c'est une
histoire faite avec des motions des
contributions
peut-être que ce que nous n'avons pas c
est pour les raisons que je vous évoquez
l'instant c'est à dire parce que les
choix se faisait par rapport aux
personnes plutôt que par rapport aux
sons ce que nous n'avons pas fait c'est
que nous n'avons pas travaillé sur la
redéfinition de ce que c'est qu'être
socialiste social démocrate pour ce
qu'il ne consomme mais socialiste dans
la période d'aujourd'hui parce que le
monde a bougé parce que les rapports ou
ont changé parce que l'individualisation
qui est le fait majeur me semble-t-il
aujourd'hui des relations humaines que
ce soit dans l'entreprise d'ailleurs où
que ce soit dans les relations de tous
les jours tous ces éléments là ce sont
sans doute des aspects que nous n'avons
pas assez travaillé collectivement et
j'espère en tout cas qu'on va s'y
atteler c'est un peu tard mais il faut
toujours essayer de le faire quand même
bon des coups les plus durs en ce moment
contre le président et contre le bilan
viennent de la gauche avec en
particulier arnaud montebourg on va
l'écouter c'était à frangy en bresse le
jour où il a annoncé sa candidature à
l'élection présidentielle
je n'aurais pas dû être là devant vous a
proposé un projet alternatif
car pour moi l'alternative était celle
que nous avions pris mettre au pouvoir
il ya quatre ans
elle était seule pour laquelle nous
étions battus pendant des années nous
avions débattu travaillé réfléchi
pendant si longtemps il non sans peine
grand galop fois cette tribune quatre
années plus tard qu'ils n'éprouvent le
sentiment d'un gâchis d'une grande
occasion manquée
ça on l'entend souvent dans la bouche
des gens qui ont voté françois hollande
ça veut dire que il est disqualifié
après ça le problème c'est que ces
accusations elles ont été portées dès le
début du mandat
dès le début du mandat et quand on est
arrivés finalement une espèce de
mécanique dans laquelle logiquement
lorsque l'on soutient une majorité on
met en avant ce qui va bien on a le
droit de critiquer les points sur
lesquels on n'est pas forcément d'accord
mais on met aussi en avant ce qui va
bien moi j'ai vécu dans la majorité
présidentielle à l'assemblée nationale
quatre en
quatre ans incessant de querelles à
l'intérieur du groupe auquel
j'appartiens est encore une fois tout ça
en fait alimenté par des ambitions car
arnaud modo que nous entendons à cet
instant c'est quand même lui qui a
participé de la déstabilisation du
gouvernement de jean marc ayrault pour
permettre à manuel valls est de devenir
premier ministre quand je l'entends
aujourd'hui critiqué le premier ministre
je lui dirai quelle responsabilité par
ailleurs quand on a été ministre de la
république pendant plus de la moitié du
mandat comment on peut faire pour ceux à
ce point se dégager d'une responsabilité
collective dans ce qui a été mis en
place chevènement disait si on n'est pas
content on ferme sa gueule ou on s'en va
pourtant mais beaucoup partent idées
franchement un bon boulot est capable de
dire des choses bon à un moment je pense
qu'il faut encore une fois intégré cet
élément là et moi je pense
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons besoin
impérativement de retrouver ce qui nous
rassemble et je suis convaincu que si on
enlève les aventures personnelles il ya
beaucoup plus de choses qui nous
rassemble compte bien le dire est ce que
françois hollande peut être candidat à
l'élection présidentielle avec un taux
de popularité plutôt d'impopularité
aussi fort aujourd'hui
est-ce que c'est pas tout votre camp qui
met en péril s'ils se présentent mais
dans aucun sondage actuellement il
accède au 2e tour de l'élection
présidentielle mais pas plus que les
autres ce qui me frappe aujourd'hui dans
les sondages à supposer qu'on puisse se
fier aux sondages de cette période aucun
des candidats de la gauche net en
situation d'être au deuxième tour aucun
et donc je dis très clairement à ceux
qui encore une fois s'en fichent
puisqu'ils sont sur la presse moi je ne
me résigne pas à ce que l'élection
présidentielle qui arrivent soit
inéluctablement un deuxième tour entre
le front national et un candidat des
républicains et encore moins quand je
regarde chez que sont les programmes des
candidats porté par le parti les
république encore moins et donc on a une
responsabilité collective il suffit pas
de le dire tu es pas de se réunir à la
rochelle pour finalement montré qu'ils
sont pas capables par lui-même alors
même qu'ils sont sur la même analyse de
ce que serait le drame de ce
gouvernement ils sont sur la même avis
ils ne peuvent pas se rassembler pour la
question qui nous est posée c'est
qu'elle est celui qui est le mieux à
même malgré tout si on veut être
objectif dans l'analyse du mandat avec
les points forts avec les poings fait
qu'est celui qui est les mieux à même de
porter cette ambition là et moi je le
dis ici à cet instant y compris en étant
conscient de ce qui se dit dans la
population jeu j'échange avec les
habitants je pense que le président de
la république est le mieux à même pour
porter les selles rassemblement là pas
une primaire ou au président de la vème
république il a rien à faire dans une
primaire avec des députés ou avec des
gens comme ça je n'ai jamais été un
grand fan des primeurs c'est pas une
surprise et je pense très sincèrement
que nous aurions pu nous éviter cette
organisation là néanmoins les fêtes de
ce que vous évoquez c'est à dire en
effet d'une situation difficile en
termes de popularité pour le président
de la république justifie sans tout sans
doute que l'on ait cette primaire
qu'elle s'organise dans de bonnes
conditions qu'elle s'organise avec la
volonté du rassemblement en tout cas
c'est cela qui me paraît le plus
important aujourd'hui
après la primaire est-ce qu'il ya le
risque de toute façon que
parler de jean luc mélenchon tout à
l'heure de toute façon socialiste sorte
de la primaire jean luc mélenchon face
12 15 14 et puis de toute façon la
primaire n'est servi à rien parce que la
gauche sera de toute façon éclatée
puisque les gens seront pas passés par
la première il ya une vraie
responsabilité collective en ce moment
car si on veut que la gauche soit
durablement éloigné des responsabilités
papa poule pour les valeurs qu'on défend
pour ce que l'on représente par rapport
aussi à ceux qui défendent les autres et
il n'a qu'à continuer comme ça et je dis
pas besoin d'aller bien regarder en
allemagne ce qui s'est passé avec die
linke qui en fait empêche la gauche
alors ils ont un dispositif particulier
à ba2 côte là bas de coalition qui
complexifie le débat par rapport à nous
mais qui empêche la gauche de reprendre
finalement un moment seul et le pouvoir
en allemagne regarder ce qui se passe en
espagne regardez ce qui se passe dans
les pays partout la gauche s'est divisée
s'est fractionné partout où la gauche a
joué finalement les aventures
individuelles elle est absente et de
manière du mail sera fractionné la
gauche parce que là vous avez vu que
même la production des sauf si on est
capable de s'interroger sur ce que le
pays peut gagner à avoir une majorité de
gauche mais majorité de gauche en phase
avec ce qu'est le pays aujourd'hui alors
est ce pas une majorité de gauche
idéalisé sur des enjeux enfin je reprend
les thématiques qui est au coeur de mon
ministère
la question bien évidemment par exemple
faut-il le protectionnisme n'est pas une
protectionnisme enfin à un moment moi je
veux bien qu'on explique t nous tous
seuls dans notre pays marine le pen ne
fait très bien d'ailleurs que tout seul
dans notre pays on va pouvoir se
défendre contre tous les autres elle
sans imaginer que lorsque par exemple
les chantiers navals de saint nazaire
sur lesquels il y a des carnets de
commandes à l'étranger vont par un
moment heureux ressentir le contrecoup
de ce que serait un repli sur soi et je
pourrais prendre comme ça beaucoup
d'autres secteurs le praticien ten
d'arnaud montebourg est-ce que vous êtes
un peu l'anti montebourg vous avez été
placé là pour ça ou pas vous êtes un
message personnel arnaud montebourg on a
jusqu'à bien que non
dans le même département c'est que vous
êtes beaucoup croisé oui mais non moi je
suis pas un petit moment et pour cause
d'ailleurs je trouve que dans ce qu'il a
mis en place lorsqu'il était au
ministère il ya des choses extrêmement
intéressante j'ai parlé tout à l'heure
des commissaires au redressement
productif je pense que son combat pour
la réindustrialisation de la france d'un
combat que je veux absolument porter de
la même manière que lorsque emmanuel
macron à incarner l'industrie du futur
je veux porter ces éléments là mais je
ne suis ni emmanuel macron ni arnaud
montebourg je me suis à la fois ni
redevable alain ni redevable à l'autre
mais en même temps dans une pour dans un
pub une poursuite de l'action
gouvernementale qui a des éléments
positifs de l'un et de l'autre et c'est
ça qui va aussi avec ma personnalité
avec met en jeu avec mes priorités
définies en actions qu'il est la mienne
on en est loin encore même si des
publics jeunes joueurs il nous reste 40
secondes émission mais juste pour avoir
une réponse vous serez candidat à votre
succession quand les législatives
reviendront quand on est ministre on est
passé à autre chose vous aurez la
réponse quand le calendrier du parti
socialiste sera ouvert bon d'accord on
n'a pas de réponse pour l'instant merci
christophe sirugue filet d'être venu
inaugurer avec nous ce premier rendez
vous politique du dimanche en espérant
que vous serez chez vous aussi nombreux
à nous suivre le dimanche que vous l'été
le samedi tout de suite la météo le
flash d'un mi journée puis dimanche en
politique continue avec la partie
nationale et pierre moscovici le
commissaire européen socialiste qui sera
l'invité du jour avec francis letellier
et il connaît bien le sujet d'alstom
puisque c'est un ancien élu du
territoire de belfort merci encore
christophe sirugue au revoir et bon
dimanche